now Ukraine says it's downed an enemy
drone that was circling above the
capital key local authorities declared
an alert for residents as anti-aircraft
units went into operation this comes a
day after Moscow accused Ukraine of
striking the Kremlin in a drone attack
Ukraine vehemently denied being involved
in that incident
Let's cross to the Ukrainian capital of
key with Charles Trafford and Charles
said to take us through what's been
happening
hi Nick yeah I suppose it was about an
hour ago before Darkness
um there was an air alert and I suppose
about 10 minutes later a loud explosion
heard what we understood to be possibly
air defense kicking into action and then
literally what seemed to be a drone
began
circling the area behind me I suppose
this would have gone on for about 15 20
minutes and I said what is so bizarre
about it is that the attempts by the
ukrainians to down it were were a
failure initially
um there was a lot of small arms fire
there was a lot of flashes in the sky of
possibly higher caliber weapons being
used and what the ukrainians are saying
was a drone continued to circle now
military analysts are beginning to say
that this could be because the Drone had
been blocked had been jammed and so it
was circling slowly but it was the
inability seemingly of the ukrainians to
be able to hit it that was so surprising
in addition to the fact that this
happened in broad daylight they seemed
to be at least one attempt using what we
presume to be some surface to air
missile uh hit it that failed and I
suppose yeah as I say about 15 to 20
minutes
later the Drone disappeared out of our
vision there was a loud explosion and we
are now beginning to see uh video which
we understood was shot on mobile phones
of a fireball descending into an area of
central Ukraine at Central Kiev the
authorities are here are now confirming
that it was indeed a drone that has been
shot down the mayor of Kiev Vitale
Klitschko is saying that a fire and a
full store four-story building has been
contained an area he says is around
about 150 meters squared he said in
terms of details of casualties that is
uh yet to be confirmed but of course
this comes after this alleged attack so
the Kremlin says against the Kremlin
yesterday something that the ukrainians
have vehemently denied and in the build
up to this counter-offensive the
Russians many Russian politicians indeed
the uh the spokesperson for the Kremlin
are calling for some sort of retaliatory
attack against Ukraine for what they say
was an attack on the Kremlin so you can
imagine the situation here in Kiev is
very tense it seems as if yeah this
drone has been down but as we go into
Nightfall now there is great
expectations of more attempted attacks
on Targets in and around the capital and
The Wider country as we saw last night
and as we've seen on three or four
occasions over the last week
all right Charles we'll leave it there
thanks that updater Chancellor for
reporting from Keith
well the Kremlin has accused the United
States of guiding Ukraine to launch that
drone attack on the Kremlin the White
House and Kiev have strongly denied
being behind the attack which reportedly
damaged the roof of the Kremlin Senate
Moscow calls it an assassination attempt
on Vladimir Putin Ellen Fisher has more
from Washington D.C
you get a sense there's a frustration
among the Americans that they're being
accused of this they've pointed out that
throughout the entire conflict which has
stretched more than a year now the
Americans have never provided the
ukrainians with any weapons to attack
Beyond its borders nor will they at this
point John Kirby who is the spokesman
for the National Security Council well
he's been doing the rounds and using
quite undiplomatic language essentially
seeing that the Russians are lying we
still don't really know what happened
um so we're we're not making an
assessment right now I did see comments
from Dimitri peskov this morning uh
Putin's uh Flack and claiming that we
had something to do with it Washington I
can assure you that there was no
involvement by the United States and
this whatever it was didn't involve it
we've seen nothing on camera from
Anthony blinken who of course is the
Secretary of State or Lloyd Austin the
defense secretary or even from Joe Biden
himself the feeling seems to be that
they're not going to put a senior figure
on these allegations that the United
States was Behind These drone attacks
because it would give them more
credibility but it's very clear from the
American side that they want the
Russians to provide proof that the
Americans were behind this drone attack
and at the moment of course they've
provided nothing like that
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
has been to the international criminal
court at the Hague pushing for a special
War tribunal zelenski met the Dutch
prime minister Mark Rooter as well as
members of parliament the ICC issued an
arrest warrant from Russian President
Vladimir Putin back in March he's
suspected of ordering the deportation of
children from Ukraine and zelenski says
the tribunal will hold Russia
accountable for its crime of aggression
of course we all want to see different
Vladimir
here
in The Hague
the one who deserves to be
sentenced for these criminal actions
right here in the capital of the
international law
and I'm sure we will see that happen
when we win
and we will win